في هذه نقلت عن قيادين عسكري كبير في احدى
دول مجموعه اكواس توقعه ان اي تدخل عسكريا
لانهاء الانقلاب في النيجر يحتاج الى
تحضير يستغرق
واوضح القياديه العسكريه ان قوه الاحتياط
التابعه عباره عن قشره فارغه حسب تعبيره
تحتاج الى تعبئه بالجنود والعتاد ونقلت عن
مسؤول دفاعيا امريكي رفيع قوله ان
التهديدات المضاده من مالي وبوركينا فاسو
وغينيا والقوات التي استولت على السلطه في
النيجر قد ترضع اكوس عن اتخاذ اجراءات
عسكريه اضافه نقلا عن مسؤول غربيا ان
المجلس العسكريه في النيجر عزز الاجراءات
الامنيه المفروضه على الرئيس بازوم بنحو
70 حارسا عشرت الصحيفه الى ان رئيس بازو
ابلغ الرئيس الفرنسي و زير الخارجيه
الامريكي بان المجلس العسكري قطع عنه
الكهرباء
وكذلك الماء سينفذ لديه قريبا
ينض